Janet aha hoysala had been destroyed and
deserted this was once a busy
neighborhood in aleppo the red door on
the left was the home of assam and alia
forced to flee they've just arrived in
the UK with their two children and his
mother mallie cool Ram dunkley is the
case worker helping them resettle in
East Kent with family still in Syria
we've hidden their faces to protect
their identity life was very difficult
we couldn't go shopping there was no
going out at all we couldn't even open
the windows because we were so scared by
the fighting I was always watching my
children because there was constant
bombing this is what they left behind
films they tell me on the road where
they once lived Islamic state fighters
have taken over their home storing
weapons in the garden and firing
missiles from the street outside
every night the family feared they would
be killed miss filter had a Baba the
problem is you don't know who's your
enemy and who's your friend my neighbor
live next door to me for years he was a
teacher and now he's a jihadi leader he
said you must give me your shop and your
house so I handed over the keys the
family don't yet speak English so Graham
explains through a translator the basics
of life in Britain from catching a bus
from the town center you can catch
different buses to different parts of
the area of you two going shopping Sundy
is a culture shock at times I mean right
now we can feel that the autumn wind is
up so it's making sure that they have
the right clothing making sure that they
know if they have children when they go
to school what they need it's been a
long journey the family left aleppo for
Lebanon from here the UNHCR deemed them
vulnerable enough for resettlement and
they were placed under the UK's refugee
scheme leaving their homeland was a
painfully difficult decision but with
two young children they had little
choice poor mad sword I was so upset
just too upset when you've left
everything your family your house but
what can you do everything is gone taken
by force there's nothing we can do to
stop it the family know they're lucky
and the children already settling at
school if your residence permits they're
also your identification with so much
behind them they say they're now ready
to begin their new lives in the UK Laura
boondock Sky News in East Kent